litres de ce lundi c'est la guerre en
ukraine des gendarmes français sont
arrivés à lviv dans l'ouest du pays ils
vont enquêter sur les crimes de guerre
commis au tour de kiev notamment sur le
massacre de boudhha massacre attribué au
russe aujourd'hui ces zones sont libérés
et les ukrainiens doivent des mines et
ses villes sylvain rousseau et notre
envoyé spécial à kiev
il y a plusieurs priorités dans ces
zones de boudhha d'hosto mail de bodo
rien kahudi repine il faut d'abord
ramassé comptabilisé autopsiés et
identifiés les nombreux cadavres que les
russes ont laissé derrière eux et puis
il y a une autre priorité peut-être même
encore plus important de ces déminer ces
zones là c'est un travail titanesque qui
se fait centimètre après centimètre
chaque rue doit être vérifiée chaque
trottoir chaque jardin chaque maison
également des mines pour vous dire ont
été retrouvés dans les habitations
cachées dans la vaisselle ou dans les
appareils électroménagers chaque porte
d'entrée de placards ou même de
réfrigérateurs et susceptibles d'être
piégés nous nous sommes entretenus un
petit peu plus tôt dans la journée avec
ole bandar qui est responsable de ces
opérations de déminage il nous a
expliqué que 550 des mineurs étaient à
pied d'oeuvre mais que la superficie
mines et en ukraine atteignait
atteindrait très probablement 300 mille
kilomètres carrés autant vous dire que
c'est un travail gigantesque c'est un
travail qui va prendre des années je me
rappelle il ya quelques années à 25 ans
après la fin de la guerre en
bosnie-herzégovine
il y avait encore des champs de mines et
pourtant des mines et c'est un préalable
nécessaire il faut d'abord enlever ces
mines pour ensuite pouvoir rétablir
l'eau le gaz l'électricité et permettre
aux habitants de retourner danser dans
ces villes là ça va aussi avoir un
impact économique très important puisque
deux champs entiers ont été minés
interdisant tout travail agricole
pendant un long moment dans ce pays qui
était le grenier à blé de l'europe